-My next guest is the host of
"WTF with Marc Maron."
And on May 16th, he'll be
honored by the Podcast Academy
as the first ever recipient
of the Governor's Award.
Here is Marc Maron!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at that.
That's what I'm talking about!
Yes!
-What's up?
-It's good to see you, bud.
I have to ask you a question
'cause I know that
you got a chance to finally
visit your mom
recently in Florida.
-I did. A while -- you know,
after I got the vaccine,
and right after, I went through
the two weeks,
I went right to Florida
to see my mother.
I hadn't seen her
in a year and a half.
It was her birthday recently.
She just turned 60, again.
[ Laughter ]
She turns 60 every -- Every year
now for 20 years, she's 60.
And we just let it slide.
[ Laughter ]
But you know what's amazing,
Jimmy?
No matter how long you don't see
your mother for,
as soon as you get there,
within 10 minutes,
you're an angry high schooler.
[ Laughter ]
Within 10 minutes, I was like,
"What?! What do you want?! No!"
[ Laughter ]
So here's what you do, Jim.
-Okay.
-Whenever you go,
when you're grown up,
if you can afford it,
never stay at their house.
Never stay
at your mother's house.
Always stay at a hotel nearby.
Not too nearby, so it gives you
time to process.
'Cause then you make plans.
They're like, "Do you want to go
to lunch?"
And you go, "Yes."
And they'll go, "Okay.
When you coming?"
Like, "I'll be over
about an hour."
Then for an hour,
you can try to reel it in,
pull yourself together.
So when you get there, you don't
yell or cry or storm away.
[ Laughter ]
-You never stay with your mom?
-No. No. No. That's horrifying.
Could you imagine waking up
and they're just there?
[ Laughter ]
I'm a grown man.
I can't do that.
-Is this the first time
traveling for you?
-Yes. I'm not scared anymore.
I got the vaccine.
I'm just going full steam ahead.
And Florida was a good choice,
because, you know, I hadn't
really been around people.
And when you go to Florida,
you're around the full spectrum
of hideous humanity.
[ Laughter ]
And they're half dressed.
Now, I'm not saying
that I'm not part of that.
I'm that judging.
We're all hideous.
But I'm about midway,
about middle hideous.
In Florida, you know what
I learned, Jimmy,
is that the expression
"does not disappoint"
goes for both good things
and horrible things.
So, here's what you see
in Florida.
It's like there's a whole
population of elderly people
that just give zero [bleep] --
Can I say that?
[ Laughter ]
They give zero.
Okay? And it's beautiful.
I saw a man wearing --
I think it must have been
a Speedo unitard.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, like, a Speedo onesie.
And he was on a unicycle.
[ Laughter ]
And, Jim, he was 92
if he was a day.
92!
-Wow!
-Everything packed
into the onesie.
And on some level, I think,
"God bless that guy."
You know, if that's who --
I think all senior citizens,
if you can't do that in reality,
at least do it in your heart.
Be the man on the unicycle
in the unitard.
-Yes, I totally agree with you.
Yeah.
Did you go out to dinner at all
while you were there
with your mom?
-Oh, man.
Look, I'm not a complain-y guy.
Alright, we went out to a place,
alright --
we went out to a place
where it was a seafood place
on the beach,
which, if you need to know,
if there is a seafood place
on the beach in a tourist town
in Florida,
they don't care
if you ever come back.
That's what I learned.
So, we got this food.
It wasn't good.
Now, here's what happens.
The next morning, because I made
the reservation online,
they send me the little,
"How was your experience
at blah blah blah?"
So I'm like, "I'm going to tell
them. I'm going to tell them."
And while I'm writing this,
I see that something happens
on my phone.
It picks up a voicemail.
But I write this thing,
and I'm like,
"The clams were disgusting.
They were stinky.
The lobster on
the chilled platter was warm.
The crab was horrible.
And the oysters were just okay."
-Do you do this ever?
Are you a Yelp reviewer?
-Never. I never do it.
And at the end of it, I said, "I
know you probably know all this,
but you really don't care,
do you?
Because you're on the beach
and you don't care
if people come back."
And I send that off, alright?
-Wow!
-So then I check my phone,
and it's a message
just by coincidence from the
manager -- the general manager
of that restaurant, saying
I left my credit card there.
[ Laughter ]
Now I'm like, "Oh, my God."
Alright, so now I got to --
I got to call the guy, right?
So I'm pretty sure in my head
that they don't read
these things.
Whatever. So I call the guy.
And I'm like,
"Hey, yeah, it's Marc Maron.
You called about
my credit card?"
He's like, "Yeah, I just --
just got the e-mail."
I'm like, "Oh, man. Yeah."
He's like, "It was like
a kick in the gut."
And, like, there's that moment,
Jim, where you're like --
The Internet is for anonymous,
one-sided attacks
that you don't have to
answer for in real life.
-Yeah, of course. Of course.
-So now I got to answer for it,
right?
So now, I tell the guy -- I tell
the guy, "Look, man, I hope --
I didn't mean to hurt your
feelings, but it was terrible."
He's like, "I don't get it, man.
I run a good restaurant.
We get the fresh fish every day.
The clams --"
I'm like, "The clams were
not good. The clams --"
He's like,
"Well, they opened them fresh."
I'm like, "Yeah, but, you know,
just 'cause a clam is closed
doesn't mean it's good.
You know what I mean?"
So I do all that.
-My God.
-And then he goes --
Then he says to me, he says,
"You know, there's a comedian
with your name, Marc Maron."
I'm like, "Oh.
Um, yeah, I'm him."
He's like, "Oh, really?
Well, my kids love you."
And I'm like, "I don't care.
The clams were bad, dude.
The clams were bad."
[ Laughter ]
"The lobster -- You're not gonna
make me feel bad.
Your restaurant's terrible.
But look, I'll come down,
get my credit card,
we'll take a picture for your
kids, and it'll be fine."
He's like, "I'm just sad
that your experience
wasn't as good
as it could have been."
I get down there, gives me
the card, we take the picture.
I'm walking off. He's still
looking at me like, "Huh?"
And I'm like, "Nope, nope, check
the clams. It was not good."
-Good for you. Good for you.
-Yeah.
I was willing to die on that
mountain, the clam mountain.
-Good. I like that,
the clam mountain.
Marc, next weekend you're
getting the Governor's Award
for the --
from the Podcast Academy.
This is the first time
they're ever doing this award.
And it's a big deal.
And I don't know. Does
Marc Maron care about awards?
-Well, you know, it's weird.
I never win them.
I've never won anything,
not since I came in second
in the San Francisco Comedy
Competition I think in 1994.
So I never win them,
and it's just ironic to me
that they had to create a new
award for me to finally win one.
[ Laughter ]
Now, the podcast award --
The Podcast Academy
is legitimate.
I don't want to disregard it.
There is a governing body.
They're legitimate people.
It's nice.
It's an important award.
It's the Governor's Award,
which basically means like,
"These guys have
doing it awhile.
We should throw them a bone."
So that's what the award is.
It's for being a pioneer,
one of the originals,
one of the people that sort of
defined the medium, a legend.
And it's usually one of those
things -- ones they give you
after people start caring about
who you are.
But I'm going to take it, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-I think you deserve it.
You were there.
You started it when
there was no one doing this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, it's very exciting.
I'm very -- It's an award
that I feel like I earned,
and I'm proud of it.
And me and my producing partner,
Brendan, we're excited about it.
-You're one of the best
out there, buddy.
And I always love
having you as a guest.
Congratulations, early,
on this award.
You deserve it, pal.
Marc Maron, everybody.
Check out his award-winning
podcast, "WTF with Marc Maron."